final moments of Batman episode 1 pose
an interesting question what happens to
Bruce Wayne when the core beliefs that
guide him are undermined episode 2
children of Arkham doesn't really answer
that question and instead shifts focus
to establishing the villain as a result
it's an episode that has some unexpected
moments but ultimately feels less
narrative Lee ambitious than its
predecessor although Bruce and his
crime-fighting alter ego might get the
most screen time Oswald Cobblepot is the
focal point of this episode let him go
Batman when we last saw him he spoke of
an impending revolution and the sparks
of that revolution ignite in episode two
telltale does a good job of presenting
Oswald as a complicated character his
actions are undoubtedly villainous which
shouldn't come as a surprise given that
he's a penguin but revelations about the
downfall of his family earned him some
sympathy you'll never quite root for him
all the Batman but when his
justifications are revealed it becomes
easier to understand what's driving him
unfortunately tell tells depiction of
penguin isn't all that charismatic he
schemes and grandstands but it's never
in a way that's thrilling to watch stage
right now alright I'll get you started
but this is your show thankfully episode
2 alludes to there being a bigger badder
villain behind the scenes this episode
is also about Bruce Wayne's father
Thomas Wayne whose deepest darkest
secrets are laid bare for all to see
what you learn about him would be more
shocking if TV show Gotham hadn't just
used a very similar plot so in that
respect telltale series isn't reading
new ground but it does place Bruce in a
much harsher light the dynamics of some
of his relationships change Harvey Dent
for example was banking on the wholesome
way name to propel his mayoral campaign
but his friendship with Bruce becomes a
liability there's a growing tension
between the two that telltale uses very
well it creates situations where lashing
out Harvey would be understandable but
knowing it could have big consequences
going forward may stay your hand the
shift in Bruce's relationship with
Alfred meanwhile is more subtle in
episode 1 Alfred is the voice of dissent
however after some hard truths about
Alfred are revealed it becomes more
supportive given what Bruce learns about
him it feels like Alfred is doing this
to recover some lost respect
or perhaps it's because he's seeing the
Wayne identity being corroded and is
pushing Bruce into seeking solace in a
new persona for the most part tell tells
Alfred embodies the faithful Butler
archetype but there are shades of
something more there which I hope I
explored further I've been dreading this
day for nearly two decades I hoped it
would never come forget the spacers I
want to hear it from you the results of
your decisions in episode 1 also start
to reveal themselves in children of
Arkham but not as significant it's
mostly whether you're friendly with
Vicki Vale or Jim Gordon based on who
you turn the evidence over to in the
last episode episode 2 has its fair
share of decision-making moments but
there's nothing much to fret over in
fact there's only really one moment in
the episode that will give you pause and
you'll know it when it happens I played
through the episode twice and the first
time around the result of my choice felt
inconsequential the second time however
the impact my decision had was profound
so I recommend switching to another
saves law and experiencing both branches
of the story while children of Arkham
pushes the story forward it takes a step
back in gameplay the crime scene
investigation which was key to making
Telltale's Game feel like a well-rounded
Batman experience is missing from
episode to this time around there's no
mystery to unravel as all the
investigations are simply a matter of
clicking a series of interaction points
the closest episode 2 gets to making you
feel like a detective is when you have
to triangulate a phone signal which
involves moving a drone around a map
until an on-screen indicator goes green
hardly detective work unfortunately
there are no other memorable moments
that will make you feel like the world's
greatest detective the puzzle like
combat sequences from episode 1 make a
return and they still feel like a clever
way to represent Batman's foresight and
battle prowess but without the crime
scene investigation and amongst all the
QTE sections it also serves to highlight
the lack of gameplay variety in episode
to anyone expecting telltale to continue
deconstructing Bruce Wayne and his alter
ego will come away from children of
Arkham unsatisfied effectively lays the
groundwork for future events with the
help of a few unexpected twists by
leaving our meaningful detective work if
all sorts of the series is first episode
yeah if I pretty good for such a pretty
boy